in your research you document many cases
where people do the right thing for the
wrong reason so for example 20th century
arbo nationalism one of my favorite uh
words from the book where many trees got
saved in a fit of nationalistic fervor
does it matter why we're saving trees or
should we just be thankful that they're
being saved regardless of the
questionable motives that may underly it
trees have been saved for the wrong
reasons for sure um there's a lot of
nasty people in my book as well well as
like glorious trees I talk about the
history of a type of protected area
called monuments of nature started in
Europe Central Europe in the late 19th
century it was kind of an answer to the
American national park a monument of
nature is like very small scale you're
protecting like an individual tree or
bog or Heath and it's often for like
scientific
reasons and it's a very beautiful idea
and it had a lot of good science behind
it and on one level you think like okay
this is all about
like kind of subnational regional even
local sense of place it's like really
beautiful right and like there's no way
that could be co-opted by you know Ultra
nationalists but of course you're wrong
right if you look at the history of like
Third Reich in fact um you know
subnationalism like haat does get
co-opted by fascists and you see this in
other instances you see in Japan you
know even like in India and Sri Lanka
with you know bod trees like there are
ways that they have been kind of caught
up in ethnonationalism and
ethnonationalist conflicts how Americans
in the early 20th century sort of
responded to that European movement for
monuments of nature this is after they
created like SEO National Park and
groups um especially groups like the
Daughters of the American Revolution but
lots of other groups protected
designated monumentalized put plaques
around trees all over the country and
they named them and it was all in
service of a very particular
white Colonial a very racist um vision
of American History does that mean we
should like tear down these trees like
no trees are wonderful and it's not the
trees's fault um are we glad trees like
that were protected of course but can we
do better yes I would say to me like one
of the great challenges of Our Moment
now is like meeting that kind of local
level love a place with this kind of
planetary crisis
the solutions to which are at such a
high level right politically and
technologically but in a democracy like
ours long may it live you need voters
who feel emotionally about you know the
Earth system but that's very hard but
you can feel about local nature so how
you kind of connect the local and the
subnational so so I do think there's a a
role for this but we should always be
wary like anything can be made fascist
by fascist right so even trees um but I
do believe that like cultivating local
place attachments so that people have a
local reason to care about planetary
management because people don't live and
feel on those terms even though we have
to we have to be thinking on both levels
and that's that's that's a roundabout
way of answering your question but uh
I'm glad these trees were protected but
we can do better we and we must yeah
thank you yeah that um the answer
reminds me of some trees close to where
I live um the Eucalyptus in the East Bay
Hills um where sort of planetary
consciousness of um you know forest fire
management is at odds with the sense of
place and the people who have fallen in
love with these trees yeah my previous
book I wrote a lot about eucalyptus that
book's called trees in Paradise at
California history and yes it was a
mistake to bring eucalyptus to
California but it was a beautiful
mistake
and it it contributes to the sense of
place for so many Californians totally
does not belong in certain situations it
can be a terrible fire hazard and but it
isn't always a terrible fire hazard it
isn't inherently terrible it's all it's
very Place specific um but you can't go
back in time you know it happened and I
think I for one and you know I think as
a historian you have to kind of
sometimes yeah you work with the world
that you were um born to right and um
you honor the mistakes of the past as
well as you know the things that you uh
agree with because you we're making
mistakes too as well as like leaving a
legacy and sometimes it's hard to know
in the moment right like what future
Generations will make of all of our
endeavors but you just have to keep
going and be generous to people in the
past as well as thinking about people in
the future that you want to be generous
to as
well